and there's participants and everything
um
okay so this is lecture two uh basically
trying to
we'll explain a bit more about q
learning some of the challenges with it
and a proposal to try to to solve it
based on some well-known ideas
so a lot of this is sort of review you
know we this connection between optical
control and rl we just said it
i'll just remind you of that this idea
of going from
dynamic programming to an lp
you know you've already seen that by
mendy in her lecture i think
other people have talked about it old
old news okay
um but then from that you get to
something that you know we just made up
this name convex q learning
um and uh basically so
my intention is to give a tutorial on
on these sort of convex analytic methods
for dynamic programming and how they
potentially could be applied to
reinforcement learning
all right and this has a long history
not just in operations research but in
the control community as well
so i'm using the same one um
so anyway we saw this already that um
if you have a uh a total cost
optimization problem like this
this would apply for example to the
mountain car problem where once you get
to the top of the hill you stop
and the cost is zero um okay
yeah there is something wrong with the
slides i i don't think that they are
forwarding maybe
hold on one second guys i'm gonna i'm
gonna have to
i see the cursor moving interest so i'm
gonna stop and
restart yeah
um
[Music]
try this again
let's see can you see this and this
yep all right okay so basically yes so a
lot of
so the first two parts of this will be
mainly things you've seen before
um but some things i don't know so some
things here i don't even know if they're
new or not
um because there's a lot i don't know
about dqn for example
so hopefully some people help me out
um so we saw this before that say for a
total cost
optimization optimal control problem we
have this dp equation
and as somebody was hinting at there'd
be a conditional expectation if this was
a markovian model
one of my intentions of doing everything
deterministically
is that the concepts carry over to the
stochastic case
without that much trouble i mean it's
this technicalities of course but
the concepts carry over really nicely
um and so we have we know we have a dp
equation for q
by introducing this notation you know
whenever you see an underbar it just
means a minimum
um and that's the thing we'd like to
solve
so that's this to review from last
lecture um
so again you know again and also this
model for your representation
um so so basically in q learning
we would like to find the theta that
gives us the smallest bellman error in
some sense
and we need a criteria for success and
that's to be one big part of today's
of this lecture is how do we decide
what's a good approximation
you know what does it mean to be close
to zero all right
okay all right
um and so let me just review the temple
difference methods first
that we know and love so
you know you can basically
do the same thing i talked about using a
[Music]
a fixed policy queue function
and so i'm not i'm sorry i don't have
the whole history but i mean this is
a standard technique in reinforcement
learning is to get be given initial
policy
approximate um the q function the fixed
policy queue function
and then update your policy so your new
policy
is defined to be the argument here so if
you solve this exactly
then that's policy iteration and it'll
converge and and you're
there's all sorts of monotonicity
properties it's awesome okay
um yeah um
but the thing is if you want to do an
approximation you again use this fact
that
for the true um the true
fixed policy q function uh it's just
observed
and uh so it's clear that you have all
sorts of algorithms
and sudden was the the god of this and
it came up with all sorts of insights on
how to approximate
this function before oh i know well
before watkins suddenly barcelo did it
um and um so again we have the same goal
um so
the um so this you know this beautiful
temple difference thing
um it's been recognized forever again
early 80s
by bartow and sudden and others
so so basically i have this expression
for the
this is my bellman error
and we can keep the same notation if i
change my notation here
so just for the next few slides when i
write down under bar
you know i'm really meaning substitution
all right
so it's just a way to keep the same
notation all right
and um yeah it's like restricting my
action space to one
one action that's my policy all right
so um you know i'm gonna still call it
td learning
somebody later tell me if i could get in
trouble for that but i'm just going to
call it td lambda even though people
call it sarsa because
basically if you're trying to estimate
the q function in this context
you're just viewing x k and uk as a
joint state process
and so it really is td lambda for a
large estate process
and i i suspect that's why the sarsa
paper never really got published because
it really
it really is this td land applied to a
different
realization of the state okay so we've
got our eligibility vector here
and we try to find the zeros of this
function
and we have to choose this eligibility
vector and we set that equal to zero
and that's the td lambda and i'll
explain
so td0 i will i will define this as
taking
the gradient of the q function i think
most would agree
but that's that's the definition of td 0
that's the choice of the eligibility
vector right there
and in td lambda you do the same thing
but you pass this through a low pass
filter
with parameter lambda okay so lambda is
between 0 and 1.
and here we'll all write less than equal
to one that's a bit dangerous in general
um but there you have it so so there's
td zero and td lambda
and the theory around this is beautiful
and i first learned about this from ben
venour's thesis
which is a absolute manifesto it's most
beautiful thesis so um
that's why i first learned about it
that's my that's just this the
trajectory i took that wasn't the
optimal trajectory but
it's a fantastic thesis um
and so basically you know you don't have
to do this everybody i mean
you know basically one could write an
ode
in this case i wouldn't recommend it
just go straight to the algorithm
um necessarily we'll see um
and you know the gain here you know you
can put in a matrix game
if you find it could be useful i'm just
saying it's an option
um and um but but you see what i'm doing
here everybody
i've got an objective my objective
you know i have to well i could say step
zero is that i want
to solve f bar of theta star equals zero
right and then step one
is to say well maybe this ode will get
me to that solution maybe the od
converges
and if it does then i have the step two
where i can do the
stochastic approximation or qsa
um approximation which is just like an
euler scheme so that's
it all right all right so there it is
and then uh so that's that's that's the
lambda and then there's
least squares sample difference learning
where i'll explain it it doesn't have to
be i'll explain it for linear
parametrization
where q theta is just the linear
combination of
features you could just look at an
average of a horizon t
of this eligibility vector times the
bellman error
and it just becomes a linear function of
theta just
invert and you've solved it all right
all right so those are two options
all right and here's a beautiful fact
i think everyone knows this here
that lstd is the same
as this approach if you choose a special
gain
you just take gn to be minus an inverse
you know
the difference is one over n squared or
something and it's i mean if well
again and alpha n plus one equals one
over n plus one i should say that
uh under those restrictions these are
the same algorithms
depend i mean maybe with an error of one
over and plus one squared if you
don't do things just right right cool
so um so there's that um now
here's the thing i mean uh these whole
four hours i'm cheating you because i'm
not talking about exploration
and i just don't have time for it here
in the control community they would call
it persistence of excitation
right and in order to get this
persistence of excitation condition
again i'm taking
i'm taking a linear parameterization for
the q function
to get this percentage of excitation
condition you're very sure they're going
to need
especially a deterministic control
problem to have something like a
randomized policy
with this ck for me it's going to be a
mixture of sinusoids if you want it
could be id
random noise or something like that now
you all
all experts i know that's not the best
way to do things okay i just
exploration is a different topic a very
important topic
i just can't dive into that there's no
time
all right um so um
so basically what i'm actually
describing here
is um this is off policy
which is known to have problems but it's
it's known
that uh this matrix does uh for
insufficiently large
uh for most d values of lambda so that's
that's
that's been known for for quite a while
now um
but and also it's known don't yell me
out
that td1 solves this amazing minimum
norm problem
so i look at the norm between q theta
and q star
the real q function um in the pi norm
i want to find pi pi is not a policy
under conditions um
and the conditions for on policy
which is so for deterministic problems
you really got a problem
you know because you can't do the
randomized policies
and so you know i won't get into the
details of what people actually do
but um clearly you all can see the
trouble
for the deterministic problem where your
goal is to reach an equilibrium and stay
there
you know everything's going to zero you
know
this i mean this is going to some
equilibrium as k goes to infinity so
it's just
there's no way you can get this without
exploration without
shaking the system all right so
um td learning methods are wonderful but
you know they take some
care in implementation but they work
beautifully
you know this this approach has had
incredible success
all right um one approach to resolving
this
is using on policy in an intrinsic
setting
and periodically resetting to basically
stop the problem
and you the the exploration is for the
initial condition
you sort of restart the system in a new
initial condition run again
restart and restart and that that
potentially
can resolve this okay
i'm not going to get into that now a
question is b
so i used to think this was the goal
and that was only my oh my math brain
talking
now for actor critic
yes as you
you've seen
um but i'm going to tell you why i
was wrong this is not the compelling
goal
in general you know um so
td1 outside of ectocritic methods
is really not that a com this this goal
is really not so compelling
outside of uh ectocritic methods i i
will explain why i feel that way
in a bit okay
all right so um so this so another
approach is a generalization of watkins
algorithm which is very
popular i don't know the name for it so
i'm going to call it q0 learning
don't tell me now if this is if it's a
standard name
tell me later um but you run watkins
algorithm
with a a function approximation setting
um and and and everything just copy and
paste
td zero and we'll call it q
q 0 in this lecture
so again as we saw before we have a
model free representation
we've seen that
we have our f bar f bar
our goal
that's step zero is to identify your
goal and in this case our goal
is this galactic relaxation of
of the melbourne equations
and and this is a very very common
approach in the rl community this is to
take this eligibility vector there
to be the gradient of the q function
okay
i think that's i think that's pretty
standard
okay so again the design principle is
the same so i'm not going to write it
down
you you analyze an ode see if it's
stable
and that can be really hard that's a
really big research topic
you know
i have an awful division condition with
that people often cite i wish you
wouldn't cite it
um and it's been improved slowly but uh
no it's just it's just this is a really
difficult problem
um getting an od that's stable but once
you get a stable algorithm then you go
through and use an euler
approximation and stochastic
approximation and you've got an
algorithm
okay um but once i want to ask now we're
going to want to challenge everybody
is why is this really a anything we
would ever care about anyway
you know that was step zero why did i
make that step zero
i mean i don't have anything so for td
learning there's such beautiful theory
to explain the motivation
for q learning it's much much more
fragile so
i want to try to have a debate
about this topic and i'll i'll i luckily
show that
yeah is it easy to explain uh
what is the beautiful thing about the td
0
goal oh i see well td0 go oh yeah
oh i'm sorry td one is is is where the
led watches okay
that tv one is the elegance it's
insanely beautiful your
td0 is not not as clear that's true um
which would say maybe we should look at
q1 well i don't know
i'm scared of that oh no no yeah um
but you and i would like td1 uh
and then there is also this thing that
dz0
if you're in a tubular setting really
just solves the model so
so in a way you can wave your hand a
little bit here and there and justify
these
yeah yeah that's right i i guess the
series so much cleaner and then td1 is
has such a beautiful conclusion it's a
miracle that td1 solves what it does
so um secular needs known to be slow
it's i don't understand the the
literature that well
but as far as i know we don't know if a
good exists in general
and and the implications of solving this
problem is not clear
and i think so so please excuse my
ignorance i'm about to go
into dangerous territory i'll talk about
something i don't know very much about
my perception is that people feel that
dqn
has helped to resolve that issue so
don't let's not have the discussion now
because
you know i i'm i'm really exposing
myself because i don't know the
literature that well but
but here's one sort of way to to write
down
the dqn using this sort of to try to fit
things into what i've talked about
before
is that i look at the the mean square
bellman error
over some uh period but
note note note i freeze
my previous estimate theta n so
you know in particular
if i had a linear permeazation
then take a look this is linear
you know this would just be the most
trivial quadratic program
yeah you know this is quadratic that's
quadratic
that's i mean people use this with
neural networks so they're not solving
quadratic programs but
you can see the beauty of this you know
but the trouble
is and and you know tell me later this
is probably well known
um uh last
month or july i was doing an od
approximation of this
and it's identical to q zero learning so
that they're identical
even for neural networks so this is
this is uh q0
so is that well known call me later tell
me later
um so let's uh yeah it's probably well
known it must be because when you
implement this you see it
um i just couldn't find a reference
before the presentation
so yeah maybe you could put a tell
everybody later
um so then so it motivates looking at
something different so let's go
let's go back to these lp approaches
that have been talked about
in recent days and uh and think about
how that might lead
to linear algorithms and this is
conjecture you know i i don't
i will propose an algorithm i don't know
if it's any good or not
um and uh and we'll see
okay so first of all i want to tell you
what is the gold standard for an
approximation
so what's a good criterion of fit i'm
going to tell you my opinion
okay all right so i've got this
so what i'm saying here is somebody gave
me a
a function j and i want to tell you
that's a good j or that's a bad j bad
job a bad job
that's a bad j trump is the only person
i can see that's why i'm picking out him
um so here so inverse dynamic
programming is this concept
is that given any function j
any function j you can make a
define a cost function and
you just take that you take the original
cost function and you subtract off this
error
you know and all i'm doing is i'm taking
that error
let's do it needs a different color i'm
taking the error
i'm putting it in here and i'm taking
this and i'm taking it out there
and that gives me this
okay so every every function
solves a dp equation perhaps with a
crappy cost function
right but then you can say
well did i do anything well so i can
take the policy that i get from this so
the policy obtained
as the minimizer all right
that the argument gives me a policy is
that clear
and then i can look at the value
function associated with that policy
and excuse the double superscripts as
eric said
um and the thing is it's
really trivial in a way um
if for example i have a lower bound on
this error
if it's greater than minus some
proportion of the cost function for all
x and u
then my optimal value function
um of course is less than the value
function
for this stupid policy that inequality
is always true
you know but then we have an upper bound
as well
you know so there's our gold standard
that's what we want
we it's sort of a uh you know that's it
so we have a gold standard
and it's also our first linear program
constraint
so looking at mean square bellman error
doesn't give us this the only thing
that gives us a performance guarantee is
something like a linear programming each
constraint
where j is the variable here you know we
don't have a parameterized family jesus
the variable
right and it's a linear constraint
that is a linear constraint
you know e is a fun is a function of j
and uh that's a linear constraint okay
so this comes to a well-known approach
that was i guess first done by man in
1960s
and you can click these at yourselves to
see other references
um you know ming d wong talked about
this
uh on monday there's a wonderful thesis
of
uh danielle de ferias with ben van roy
and sadly she left mit the day i arrived
my sabbatical in
in 2008 to dance tango in new york
um and it's one way to derive these
semi-definite programming
representations of lqr
um and you can you can find every single
month as a new application
in the control community all right i
mean just
i won't i will list them okay so so
basically i take some
probability measure on the state space
you know
x could be rn and mu could be a gaussian
density i don't know
um and uh i have a inequality constraint
that that uh looks bellman equation like
and uh in this general setting i would
need the continuity of j
and and in this total cost problem i
need equilibrium
and j to be zero at the equilibrium so
uh you can find details
uh in in those lecture notes that i sent
to you all
all right so this is this is this is
known as an approach to approximate
dynamic programming
typically model based there's no queue
and whenever you don't see a cue you
should see a sad phase
right okay
so you can introduce a cue so you cram
in a q
so before i had j was less than this
i've just snuck in a q here and here
you know i'm just sandwiching i'm saying
q is less than the thing i had before
but q is also bigger than j and then the
same other assumptions
um and now i've got something that you
can imagine
it's easy to make a model based
representation of error
and you get q q learning algorithms
okay yeah so um
this um this over parametrization as far
as i know
it's my own work in 2009 with prashant
mehta
and the reason we did it was just
because of this
you know basically we can observe this
and then get a reinforcement in the
algorithm
okay
okay so how do you do it
um
should i drive this i wonder
what time is it all right
it's two o'clock that's it i don't have
that much to say so let's do it
so so remember that we had that this was
this was our this was our constraint
for um this is a classical thing
you know no q so how do you derive the
classical result
um you know you basically use the fact
that
those are my dynamics that's exactly
equal to that you know
f defines my next state given my current
state in action
um and you can iterate this you know
and you get this
all right because i have j times k
compared to j
of time k plus 1 so you can iterate the
equation
and you get this and so yeah this is
useful to say
um so you have this for every t and then
you'd like to get t go to infinity and
what's the issue
i'm trying to get a bound on j and the
issue is
that you don't know much about this
you know as t goes to infinity what's
happening to this thing
but so this goes to zero for policies of
interest
so basically i'm going to only look at
inputs for which i have stability
so my control problem is to try to get
to the top of the hill and stay there
that's the equilibrium
and uh so i'm gonna basically
um you know for any stabilizing policy i
get an upper bound
and the optimal policy is an example so
i can just go through it i
minimize this overall all stabilizing
policies
i get an upper bound um
so i take the theme over all u and by
qed i mean that
j of x is less than equal to j star of x
for all feasible j
right and so that's why you have to
maximize you know
you're always getting a lower bound on j
um
sorry that minimizing cost everybody and
so that's why you have to do something
like this
you know introduce a weighting and then
maximize
okay and that's it so that's how you
prove it
and then the the the the q learning
flavor is just use a sandwich and thing
so it's the same
it's the same thing questions
all good
we kind of believe you there's some
details
but yeah you know but then
but the biggest thing is the reason for
going over this is the fact right there
that this equation is exactly the same
as this equation they're identical
it's it's a definition of a model i
guess i should keep writing down my
model
yeah yeah
that should be that should have been
heavy slide sorry everybody
yeah okay
i had to copy that i'll bet i'll need it
again
okay um
[Music]
yeah so so um so it's obvious you can
get a
i hope this is a joke it's it's obvious
to all of you that you can get a
quadratic program
i hope because what i can do is i can
redefine my bellman error
as this linear function of my variables
so
q and j are variables if you like
they're in a finite state space and
actually you know
an action space they'd be variables
they'd be like you consider them as
vectors
they're functions in general so it's an
infinite dimensional problem
but e is a linear function of
q and of j and so when you square it if
you like
i get a linear function of q and j and i
can take another
probability measure mu nu there and hit
it by this thing
and i won't change the problem at all
because at an optimizer
this whole thing becomes zero you know
so adding this term here is vacuous
because the optimizer already satisfies
that that's equal to zero
so there's no theorem here at all you
know
we we already had again uh e is
identically zero for
for the optimum
okay i guess we'll see why you're doing
this
cuba seems to be more complicated happy
yeah yeah
it's it's it well it it it's because of
the fact that
there's a regularization issue i think
i want the flexibility i just you know
there's a regularization issue in an
algorithm
um and i
i so much i want this to be zero and i
want to try to encourage it
and the lp might not give enough
encouragement um
and constraints can be really hard to uh
you know constraints like this can be
really hard to manage in algorithms
so it's just another another uh thing
you can play with
all right um
yeah also reminds me of
that people doing optimization right
they
take the pain that they have they square
it
move it to the objective they argue that
the problem hasn't been changed so this
is kind of
the same thing right oh that's right
that well my motivation was all
that theory and the theory of
regularization and in constrained
optimization
it really came from those ideas
absolutely and at one point
i had a positive part of this the
objective squared
which is also convex um because you take
a pilot you take a difference positive
part is convex squared it's convex
um and you can do that too so you can
you can do also put in all sorts of
penalty terms
to help regularize this problem
yeah okay and um
and i say the the um
the objective and constraints can be
observed without a model i should have
put in my gold standard
as well so you could do that as well
okay so that's so yeah this is cool so
um
i didn't have to feel rushed so i'm just
going to go through and say
here's a possible killer nail good can
get out of this
one of you please come up with something
better by october
before halloween how's that um
so basically
here is a a model free
if you like hulani algorithm and let's
try to make sense of this
so don't worry this is not an algorithm
yet i'm just trying to come up with
something
so um so
a few things a few warnings okay so
i'd like this to hold you know
this is this is model three
and i'd like it to hold most of the time
it may be my parameterization's too
small to make it hold every
for every k you know that's a question
this is this is an open question
now this is also model free
because this is just a a um
[Music]
i'm going to impose this on my
approximation architecture
so i did some experiments and i tried to
enforce this using
monte carlo blah blah blah forget it it
was too it was unstable
it was just awful so just construed
or maybe some people have a better idea
so i i failed to
to do this without imposing it to the
architecture
it's related advantage functions yes is
that
so for example one way of doing this
would be just to define
j as the minimum in the u of q would
that
kill things they're going to convexity
exactly the whole thing is no longer
convex
yeah this yeah i guess these days people
are not that much concerned about that
but
yeah that would be yeah yeah yeah um
[Music]
yeah okay that's true
that's true good point
that's a good point yeah um
[Music]
oh you couldn't have wait wait
um oh no no you get really screwed if
you define
j to the minimum of q then you're back
to watkins
you know q zero watkins you mean you you
can't you need the two two variables
um you'll get this you'll just go back
to dqn yeah
um now now here's what you know
this um this constraint
i wanted this to be non-negative
i'm going to relax that in the same way
that we do these relaxations in key
learning
i'm going to take this maybe a high
dimensional vector
so theta might be dimension a thousand
but this might be mentioned in a million
you know because it's an inequality
constraint i'm unbound it could be as
high dimension as you want
um and i've found in experiments i do
need to take it fairly high dimensional
and um and so basically
i replace this being true for every k
with a with a galactic relaxation
and you see that i'm copying the
notation i used
in the in dqn i'm going to be looking at
batches
okay all right
so this is this is a relaxation
okay and then you know of course
i have this funky thing up here what the
hell do i mean by that
now there i have to use an empirical
average so you'll place this thing here
with what the hell is that but you look
at the
the bellman error at time k square it
and take the average
so here i can do it because convex if i
mean
if you have a linear probabilization
it's convex
it's a neural network it's not but still
i'm
i still say there's a big difference
even if it's not convex
between what i'm proposing here in dqm
um so here's an algorithm with those
definitions so
um i do a batch method and
i solve exactly this
this again if it's a linear function
approximation this is a quadratic
program
and i do a primal dual method i have not
seen is the only way to go again
where i relax my constraints that this
is great equal to zero
so i have this constraint that that's
equal to zero i relax it through the
lagrange multiplier
um and this the standard primal dual
update is this thing here
all right and it's you know and it seems
to be
i don't know i mean this this thing's
not very old so i don't
i can't tell you how great it is all
right so
so there's one proposal one can try and
there it is
any questions i'm sure there must be
um so sharon is asking okay yeah i have
a couple more slides but yep
yeah sharon's asking we are penalizing
twice
once the average in the objective and
then again via
said um oh wait hold on a second um
yes we are but that's the regularization
question absolutely so
i don't know if i
that's an open question setting this
equal to zero
it seems to be fine but i've done a
total of two experiments
i don't know anything i just i'm just
saying there's lots of options here okay
so you're right we're we're doing things
twice we've got we've got uh
but think about the slow start issues
here like in beginning lambda means
nothing at all
so this is sort of a surrogate for this
uh term here
you know in the beginning lambda means
nothing
um yeah but my head is buzzing
with with improvements of this i'm going
to keep my mouth shut
yeah is that this is augmented language
if you believe in augmented language and
being a good thing then
the good thing actually i ran two
experiments
a similar setting and the augmented
language engine always means it's
just way way better if you want to solve
uh these constraint problems
yeah so i'm very much you so
but so everybody um the reason it's not
it's it's not quite the augmented
lagrangian
because i have an inequality constraint
here
and here i didn't take the positive part
yeah and my motivation is because i know
that
with equality here it's also a valid
quadratic program
yeah over constrained if um
if we can't if we don't have the true
value function in our
in our basis so i'd say it's almost like
a bit of lagrangian
um but okay cool that yeah thank you
very much i
uh that's helpful anything else
i have a few more slides um and yes oh
yeah that's the learning rate
yes yeah and and but
yeah so the real question that if you're
reading the question
is uh if the learning rate is decreasing
that that term seems to be blowing up is
it a problem i started to type some
answer but
you you better answer it well it turns
out i i wish i could write it down but
if you actually go through suppose that
so you notice i've got this
constrained optimization it's a
quadratic program but
it does have it's got linear constraints
in general or
convex constraints because i'm going to
impose
a relationship between q and j
but if you write this down um
take the gradient set equal to zero
you're going to get something that looks
just like stochastic approximation
or or an earlier scheme this will end up
looking like a gain
um so the fact that it blows up
it's just like a a vanishing game
uh in a uh in a standard um
i say oh you know standard algorithm
okay
um i mean you're gonna get you're going
to get theta n plus 1
equals some crazy function
gradient something really complicated
you're gonna when you solve this
minimization problem
so it's so that that's why there's a one
over alpha n plus one
okay cool um so
it's only four weeks old everybody you
know and i'd hoped to
work on this more but nips were in my
life in july
um and uh you know
so it's like that's the optimal value
function you'd get if you in suddens
mountain car problem
and you know this was when i
i got tired in early august and stuff i
don't have time for this
um and it was you know not nearly enough
time has been put into this um
i have no idea if this is going to be an
amazing breakthrough
or just a cute comment um but
but i'm doing this i'm not wasting your
time because
the value look what i got to explain
my feelings of shortcomings in q
learning the way in which
the lp approaches can be made into
model-free
reinforcement learning algorithms and a
lot of potential directions for research
so i
i did not waste your time i don't think
even though this is very i'm just even
though it's just a proposal
um so yeah again lessons learned
one again is that this difference
again i told you this already but this
is called the advantage function
the difference between q and j and again
i wasn't able to get anything to work
without
imposing this through the structure of
the architecture
um i think that there may be sensitivity
to this
in lqr there's not it's trivial you can
just take
indeed to mention these points of
support and and you're done
that's an open question um and a warning
to everybody
i discovered in this in trying to get
things to work the
main reason that some of these these
problems in open ai are hard
is because they come from continuous
time problems and they've translated
discrete time with fast sampling
and what happens then is that
this xk plus 1 is almost the same
as xk that's supposed to be an
approximation symbol
right and if if this is almost the same
as this
then that's g of x k and
i've got a q minus j that's the
advantage function
and so basically i'm trying to make that
zero
that's not a good thing making the
advantage function the cost function now
so the only reason i had trouble
was the super fast sampling rate on open
air gym
so i i know that if you
if you go and look at things carefully
in continuous time
and come with really robust algorithms
and continuous time
then go back and translate them you'll
get more robust algorithms i
i feel that deep down in my soul that's
true
that you shouldn't you shouldn't settle
with the continuous the
fast sample discrete time model is
reality
we have a lot of flexibility in in how
we
choose well how we implement these
algorithms
i'll put it that way okay sean that's
going to generate a lot of questions yep
a quick question about the choice of zed
and
how did you choose that n oh yeah so i
took um
um i said again let me go back to that
that's it
okay yeah so what i did
um oh no no
so yeah so so what i did is just this
and the obvious thing that you might do
is i basically took um
the pace you know i took so
so um
um it's an rbs
so yeah i take some yeah i take some
sort of a gaussian
kernel society k plus it's ith entry
is equal to some gaussian density
how about that
gotcha
um yeah that's that's one thing and of
course that
i'm sure you know you could do simpler
things it's just you know
that's one possibility um it's kind of
mixing
the linear representation of linear
parameterization with this
non-parametric ideas
yeah i and the thing is i'm most excited
about trying this out for kernels
because i
in the in the lecture notes i sent to
all of you
there's a proposal to on how you do this
for kernel methods and it's uh
it's going to be fun to try out um it's
um so yeah so
the so yeah again the thing is that in
the end
the similarity to dqm is so compelling
that people would think that i'm sort of
reinventing something
but here we're solving
potentially the gold standard or trying
to approximate it
and the other thing we don't know
anything about it you know we don't
yet know what this means
you know and someday we might have a
better theory you know that's just uh
the current theory of q learning is
quite is weak and it's going to improve
i know that
okay um you know stochastic control
is not a big deal everybody it's not a
big deal
uh going from the what the deterministic
theory is presented to you the
stochastic
i that's not my concern i think that the
computer engineering is a concern
you know how did the most robust way to
translate these
ideas and algorithms is going to take
some real
both the math rl people and the computer
engineers
will have to work together um and i
think it'd be so cool if there's a
convex policy gradient
because after all mandan wasn't obsessed
with value functions
he was obsessed with uh you know with
the probability
on state action pairs and so maybe we
should be parameterizing
occupancy probabilities and not the
policy
you know come on i mean i'm just i'm
i'm half kidding okay i don't know the
whole diff
is raging are they okay i didn't know
that yeah
i'm told it's well known uh
it's uh it's a thing for sure
yeah yeah okay cool cool cool so yes so
i'm not aware of that literature
but um but yeah so then they didn't look
at the duel huh that's funny
yeah and to me the reason i laugh is
because
coming up with a a
the is out the window i mean how on
earth are you going to come with a
proposal
for convex family of um occupancy
probabilities
just uh that's all but okay so
um what i want to do so that you know so
we're done with
part one part two is all about quasi
sean
and all these quasi-stochastic
approximation
and and gradient descent methods and
ectocritic methods
um and what do i mean by the od method
and especially the od approximation of
the dqm so the next two hours
are going to be diving deeply into that
but not i won't be super technical
i have emergency exit buttons to jump
out of anything scary
so and you can stop me as well
but that's uh yeah
yeah that's it right
yeah and then this this will adapt to us
more questions come on
uh are you um in the kayaks in in one of
those kayaks uh
on the picture yeah yeah well um
i do have friends uh associated with
each of these kayaks
this is rowing actually yeah this is
actually growing yeah that's right
this is rowan um but there could be
kayaks as well
um you know what this is on top
so i'm not gonna be like chris watkins
and wait till september
2020 to tell you that the q function was
just a random choice
you know what this beautiful sunset is
no so so my laptop had a clock speed
about 500 kilohertz i think
and i had a an m a q learning problem
running
and when i woke up in the morning it
showed me this
it's a randomized policy
nice isn't that it's like a gift from
macintosh
so matlab created the colors and i i
improved them a bit
but yeah you know probably the red means
probably
zero and the blue is probably one you
know
yeah so this is i've always wanted to
use this sunset and i finally found one
yeah but the boots were not there
no no yeah this up this upper rectangle
is a randomized policy
right yeah and in june i was thinking
how do i make use of this and i realized
if it's a sunset i need an ocean before
it so
i see uh okay there is a question in the
meanwhile in the chat
are ectocritic methods less prone to
instability
near locally optimal solutions
stochastic and value-based methods
oh no it seems like there's more than
one question there
um so the i'm
definitely not yeah i'm not the one to
answer that question about
the reliability of active critic versus
q learning
um i'm definitely not the one but i'm
going to
present some compelling results in the
non-stochastic setting
where i feel it kicks ass you know
for deterministic exploration um
but i sure don't know i i don't have
much expertise in experiments with
vector critic
so maybe somebody else could chime in
you know they're very strong opinions
on you know favorite approaches to q
learning does anybody out there
feel like the actor critic is the only
way to go i know some people feel that
way
i don't know it's not me yeah i mean
obviously approximations are useful
but uh it seems to me that you can
continuously interpolate between these
algorithms it's not like this
binary thing that either you do do that
like everything is like entangled
uh maybe the question is whether
instability
would actually be a big problem with
value-based methods let's say just focus
on that because actor critic didn't
quite oh i see no uh
well instability is an open problem for
for
um for watkins algorithm with
with general function approximation or
dqm
but for this algorithm is a piece of
cake
i think that we do have examples that
show that there is instability
like oh no no no no no that's not what i
of course it's bard's count example
there they're kind of they're
examples where it doesn't work what i
mean is getting a general sufficient
conditions
for stability of watkins algorithm with
function approximation
the current sufficient conditions are
just they're just they're
their weight they're not nearly tight
i'm sure
yeah yeah do do you think that we can
ever get to
some answer that you would be happy with
in terms of
you know like we would be happy with the
sufficient and necessary condition
but isn't that too much to ask for and
if you're not getting
conditions then like what are we doing
like yeah we can try to get
better uh sufficient conditions but um
yeah i i i wish that
i mean my dream would be to find it a
really robust way to
reach my gold standard because i mean
that is what we want we want
we want when you have a l
an lp type bound on the bellman error
then you have a performance guarantee
you know stability yeah all sorts of
things you know but these other things
it's just hard to see what you're doing
um you know um so i don't know if i'll
ever be satisfied that's you that's
about
um uh let me push on this
uh stability instability so there are
multiple ways
of defining stability one would be just
that
you know things don't blow up yeah um
so in that sense like do we actually and
i i think that you were talking about
convergence right like
actually converging uh so what's your
opinion how
important it is to design algorithms
that converge under some
uh well-defined conditions which have
reasonable conditions
versus you could have an argument which
you know chatters around but
uh but the others are controlled
oh yes sure no i mean i don't mind
i mean i think that the main reason the
mathematical side
of rl all not all of it
one one sector of the mathematical side
of rl
looks at vanishing gain algorithms
because you can prove beautiful results
but in practice i think that
having you know chattering is is fine
you know um and and
and again you could always average at
the end the pull that cooper sort of
thing
um uh if you don't like the chattering
you know um so you know i'm not worried
about chattering but you want it
but the thing is if there's shattering
then there's a steady state and you'd
like property is a steady state
you'd like it's mean to be close to what
you'd like it you know it should be um
things like that
not too much chattering yeah
yeah i'll even talk about that
okay uh so in the meanwhile on discord
another
super important question about the cover
um
but whether the bird that is a zebdas
oh yes of course by the way this is
this is stable because you can do an od
analysis of this it's stable
and zapdos is right there
of course that little bird
uh has been a friend for the last three
years uh
and that's sort of the uh the trademark
for aditya devaraj's thesis
um
uh uh on zebra learning sean let me just
let me just say something okay
so uh so this is gargay uh so
uh let me just say that your talk just
totally blew my mind
especially just this part where you
introduced the queue function in the
linear program
yeah because this is something that i
just discovered this spring
i don't know i was just modeling around
with the lp's
and so so this really just
changed my world in every possible sense
i mean when it comes to like
reinforcement like that is
yeah because before that you know i'm
i'm a little bit of an
lp fundamentalist which is like you know
whatever can be explained in this lp
framework exists
in mvps and everything else is fiction
yeah
and also i think is it it's such a
beautiful tool for analysis it's amazing
yeah
yeah totally and i was like few
functions do not make any sense
because there's no queue functions in
this lp right yeah
right right trying to like play around
with it
and then i came to the exact same
formulation as you did
except that i think that uh replacing
one of the inequality constraints with
an equality constraint
has some advantages and i actually
derived some algorithms from this
uh so i was like sort of like
interrupted also by this norip's
deadline
yeah so some some horribly like
mutilated version of this lp appears
in one of my nerf submissions oh really
and but like regarding also this kind of
penalized lagrangians and introducing
these regulation terms so like
yeah i mean i've been going through like
exactly
oh through the same that's awesome we
have to keep the conversation going
yeah absolutely absolutely we're gonna
have something to talk about in these
coming months because this is
that's completely fascinating yeah yeah
that's the thing
i was so excited about getting some
feedback because it's
so you know again we had a version as a
continuous time in 2009
and and it was like and we laughed at
ourselves because we didn't
you know i in my mind rl
is about algorithms you know theta n
plus 1 equals theta n
and and i didn't have the dqn batch
mindset
and without that it's a mess it's just
trying to make this into a recursive
standard you know it's it's it's just
it's it's
it's not possible so we oh yeah that
means the game
thing was from that paper so we applied
it to music games
and um so we were able to to make it
work
but the lp um
was hard to manage at the time um just
because we were conservative we
we had a view of what algorithms should
look like
yeah so my idea of deriving algorithms
is usually
like coming from the perspective of the
duel of this
because because from the dual you can
just
like impose like different kinds of
regularization and derive like a bunch
of different algorithms from it this is
something that i really love to do
and like once you introduce this extra
constraint in the dual as well
like once that you know once in the in
your primal you include
an inequality constraint you're going to
have an unconstrained variable in the
dual
oh okay yeah and and for that sudden
okay so my other pet peeve is that the
squared loss does not make any sense
right
just like the q function but once you
have an unconstrained variable then the
square law suddenly starts to make sense
and for me you know this is all coming
together i can go on forever like this
i don't think this is interesting yeah
yeah
that's fun though oh all right that's
right
so yeah we need to totally talk about
this layer oh that's great
yeah and um
yeah yeah so thanks for sharing your
thoughts yeah thanks for the feedback
that's fun
it seems that multiple people are coming
to your
similar ideas recently suniya was
sending a message
in the chat that they also had some
happy formulation of his q functions
in an earlier work uh so there will be
something to discuss about
later and uh also she's asking
whether extending to stochastic control
would present some
challenges with this uh you know like
you have
an error type of quantity uh in
expectation there
and then squaring uh okay yeah so
yeah i have two answers to that so so
without the penalty
it's it's completely trivial so this
this
this presents problems in a stochastic
framework
yep um yes indeed
so so you'll have to kill it or come up
with something else
um right you want it to be
yeah so there's also there's all sorts
of tricks to do with that yes you can
use it
you know yeah you can use what are they
called again belief buckets
yeah you can use empirical models also
there's a million ways you can deal with
it
um yeah um
yeah but yeah you can you can't take
this off the shelf but there's lots of
ways to
to come up with alcoholics
i can't cut you off yeah um
yeah so can we have one more question
maybe uh
then we should let people go um so the
question is
uh in general since what is the
advantage
of construct con constructing a problem
in terms of
solving heb activation this is iterative
rl
i'm not sure i understand
the question uh whoever asked it it was
an
and it was at uh if if you want to
refine your question i'm
i don't know whether shown you
understand uh the question
maybe this person's actually read this
paper
because that's what this is about oh
okay there you go
so oops obviously i
reviewed my spot so then
but but the advantage i think is because
of this issue of fast sampling
is that basically fast sampling
continuous time
it's like the problem with
differentiation
excuse me problem
yeah well then you can't differentiate
your measurements
so most of our paper was about how to
comp with new dp equations
in which we we could take in average
data
and then get it and get a unbiased uh
algorithm
um so i think you can import and this is
a great example
of ods calculus is beautiful i'm sorry
lps are beautiful
but it's always calculus by spending so
much time to continuous time case i
think there's all sorts of tricks to
justify averaging data and solve the
exact
uh dp equation okay
so um so that's a potential answer to
that question
it's an answer to some questions i do
have um
a follow-up question to this then which
is that
okay so um if fast sampling
happens to be the case uh then maybe
that suggests that you should be
uh approximating gradients of the value
function
uh right like
uh how far like what is the direction of
change
of uh the value um
and that's basically the heb thing but i
have to should we should do it in a in a
smooth
way so that like you don't need to know
whether you're in this scenario or that
scenario like i'm like
system is just discrete time and maybe
you need this representation or that
um yeah so have you
do you have any thoughts about this
am i accomplishing
it's it's a fun question but i don't
um it's so funny because that's
actually part of so so
estimating the gradient
um the gradient oh nobody
with respect to x not
yeah usually even talking about distance
there is continuous
space and you're estimating expect to
yeah i don't know i don't know if
they're useful or not it's
great it's interesting all right yeah
um something's curious
good um thanks uh sean
uh okay so let's pick up an ore
um and we'll come back after the break
oh and the break yeah i can check the
schedule myself okay
thank you oh bye uh did you post your
slides for this part uh
i i can post all four right now where
should i send it
a disclosure discussion channel for the
workshop
uh okay all right if you have a problem
just let me know also i'll just uh
use dropbox yeah and then
pause the link yeah that's good very
cool
alright see you later see